in the rise of deep learning one of the
most important ideas has been an
algorithm called batch normalization
created by two researchers Sergey iov
and Christians a greedy batch
normalization it makes your hyper
parameter search probably much easier it
makes your neural network much more
robust to the choice of hyper parameters
is much bigger range of hyper parameters
that work well and they'll also enable
you to much more easily train even very
deep networks let's see how batch
normalization works when training a
model such as logistic regression you
might remember that normalizing the
input features can speed up learning in
computer means subtract off the means of
your training set computer variances
this sum of X I squared this is a
element wise squaring and then normalize
your data set according to the variances
and we form an earlier video how this
can turn the contours of the learning
problem from something that might be
very elongated you know something that
is more round and easier for an
algorithm like gradient descent to
optimize so this works in terms of
normalizing the input feature values to
a new network or to logistic regression
now how about a deeper model you have
not just input features X but in this
layer you have activations a one in this
layer you have activations a two and so
on so if you want to train the
parameters say W 3 B 3 then one would be
nice if you can normalize the mean and
variance of a two to make the training
of W 3 B 3 more efficient in the case of
logistic regression we saw how
normalizing x1 x2 x3 maybe helps you
train W and B more efficiently so here
the question is for any hidden layer can
we normalize the values of a let's say a
2 in this example but really anything
later so as to train W
bb3 faster right since a2 is the input
to the next layer that therefore affects
the training of w3 and b3 so this is
what passional does batch normalization
or national for short does although
technically will actually normalize the
values of not a two but z 2 there is
some debate in the deep learning
literature about whether you should
normalize the value before the
activation functions on v2 or whether
they should normalize the value after
applying the activation function a to in
practice normalizing z2 is done much
more often so that's the version I
present and what I would recommend you
use as a default choice so here is how
you would implement batch norm given
some intermediate values in your neural
net let's say that you have some hidden
unit values z 1 up to ZM and this is
really from some hidden layer so it be
more accurate dividers as if the some
hidden layer I for I equals 1 through m
but to videos writing I'm going to omit
this square bracket L just to simplify
the notation on this line so giving
these values what you do is compute the
mean as follows again all this is
specific to some layer l but I'm waiting
the square bracket L m and then you
compute the variance using the pretty
much the formula you would expect and
then you will take each of the i's and
normalize it to get zi normalized by
subtracting off the mean and dividing by
the standard deviation um for numerical
stability we usually add epsilon to
denominator like that just in case Sigma
squared turns out to be 0 and some
estimate
and so now we're taking these values E
and normalize them to have mean 0 and
standard unit variance so every
component of Z has mean 0 and variance 1
but we don't want the hidden units to
always have mean 0 and variance 1 maybe
it make sense but hidden units to have a
different distribution so what we'll do
instead is compute the call to Z tilde
equals gamma Z I known plus beta and
here gamma and beta are learn about
parameters of your model so they're
using gradient descents or some other
algorithm like the gradient descent with
momentum RMS proper atom you would
update the parameters gamma and beta
just as you would update the weights of
the neural network now notice that the
effect of gamma and beta is that it
allows you to set the mean of V total to
be whatever you want it to be
in fact if gamma equals square root
Sigma squared plus Epsilon
so if camera were equal to this
denominator term and if beta were equal
to MU so this value up here then the
effect of gamma xenon plus beta is that
it would exactly invert this equation so
if this is true then actually these
older I is equal to VI and so by an
appropriate setting of the parameters
gamma and beta this normalization step
that is these four equations is just
computing essentially the identity
function but by choosing other values of
gamma and beta this allows you to make
the hidden unit values of other means
and be
winces as well and so the way you fit
this into your neural network is whereas
previously you are using these values V
1 Z 2 and so on you will now use Z 2
there I instead of Z I for the later
computations on your network and we want
to put back in this sum square bracket L
you know to explicitly to know which
layer it is in you can put it back there
so the intuition I hope you take away
from this is that we saw how normalizing
the input features X can help learning
in a neural network and what - alone
does is apply that normalization process
not just to the input layer but to the
values even deep in some hidden there in
the neural networks we apply this type
of normalization to normalize the mean
and variance of some of your hidden unit
values V but one difference between the
trading inputs and these hidden unit
values is you might not want your hidden
unit values to be forced to mean 0 and
variance 1 for example if you have a
sigmoid activation function you don't
want your values to always be clustered
here you might want them to the larger
variance or have a mean that's different
than 0 in order to better take advantage
of the non-linearity of the sigmoid
function rather than have all your
values being just listed within your
vision so that's why with the parameters
gamma and beta you can now make sure
that your VI values have the range of
values that you want but what it does
really it ensures that your hidden units
have standardized mean and variance
where the mean and variance are
controlled by two explicit parameters
gamma and beta which the learning
algorithm concentr whatever one so what
it really does is it normalizes in mean
and variance of these hidden unit values
really the VI to have some fixed
mean and variance and that mean and
variance could be 0 and 1 or it could be
some other value and is controlled by
these parameters gamma and beta so I
hope that gives you a sense of the
mechanics of how to implement a tional
at least for a single layer in the net
in the next video I want to show you how
to fit bash them into the neural network
you can deepen into network and how to
make it work for the many different
layers on your network
and after that will give some more
intuition about why bash storm could
help you train your network so in case
why were filthy a little bit mysterious
stay with me and I think in the two
videos from now we'll really make that
clearer